this is a production of Cornell
University
all right thank you thank you for your
introduction and inviting me to share
um my my work and I hope this will be an
opportunity to find a more Mutual
interests uh
um with with the colleagues at Cornell
so as you see here today my my
presentation title is data science about
human environment systems for
sustainable development
oh okay so today's agenda first up first
I will briefly introduce my the
motivation and the framework of my
research program then I will talk about
two empirical components one is pastoral
systems or dry land system the second is
a global land rush I will explain the
terms later and then towards the end I
will talk about future directions and
synergies
um
all right first of all on motivation and
framework
so the big question in my in my research
program is to answer the question of how
to achieve synergistic outcomes in human
well-being and the environmental
sustainability in the context of our
Global development and this question is
largely aligned with many of the
sustainable development goals which
represent our Universal culture and
poverty protect the planet and ensure
that everyone lives in peace and
prosperity
and my work is largely uh International
uh we are which rests on large
collaborative uh networks so in Asia but
so I worked in um in primarily in
western China in xinjiang um the
predominantly
um the ethnic region of China like the
it's China's Muslim part like with
uyghurs conducts they're starting the
Pastoral system there and um and also
with Tibetan villagers to study the
energy transition
um process under the targeted poverty
alleviation program of the central
government
sending Africa mostly Ethiopia
um so for my this is my PhD project and
I went to Southern Ethiopia to study the
dry land systems how like a pastoralists
their lifestyle interact with their
rangelands and uh this is a started from
my postdoc project I started land tenure
change and its consequence of land cover
change and smallholder livelihoods at
the local level but later I will also
talk about this topic at different
scales
and then in North America like when I
was a graduate student here
um
um I engaged with this um
um the farm worker program and I went to
teach English to to this migrant Farm
Workers from Latin America and among
that my those with undergraduate
students and many of them like that I
went to teach like this big this this
graduate students who have interest in
this they typically speak very good
Spanish so soon after after five minutes
then the conversation switched into
Spanish and I'm because I don't speak
Spanish so I I think I fulfilled that
goal of teaching English to the Farm
Workers better than those undergraduate
students
but anyway so that's my experience with
that and also in Phoenix so like we have
some um small projects with Hispanic
communities just
um on Urban guard Urban Community
Gardens or was how to enhance local food
security and food access
so like as you can see here so I I
conducted a work in many different parts
of the world that therefore I really
echoism at least in my field there is a
transition from International
Development to Global development right
internet will usually think of oh
development is just out there it's a
question out there but it is question
also a question right here right so
that's why I really Echo is this kind of
transition and I'm that and I'm very
excited to join a department called
Global development
so that's some of the background then
theoretical framework so my my research
is largely involved owned by this kind
of um couple system
um approach which is also largely
promoted by NSF well as one of their uh
very few regular interdisciplinary
programs and different terms have been
used to to to name this system right
human environment social ecological or
careful human natural but at the core of
those um of this couple system is about
the interactions both within the natural
and the human system and across those
systems
but um are like moving that forward like
I think uh the recent frontiers of
starting social ecological systems is to
analyze the joint outcomes right so when
there's interactions like what's the
implications of human well-being and on
on environmental sustainability in the
context of climate change environment
degradation or land energy change
but I was at um but I would also
highlight that actually the Justice
outcome of all those kind of in of uh
interactions is gaining more and more
like um attention and uh and the
significance in uh recent scholarships
so I will also talk about later like
later in my talk how this
um sdg sdg 10 is considered in my in my
work
and then just one slide on the masses so
I use a data size and also a different
um like mixed methods to answer the
question of on on environmental sustain
on how to achieve synergistic outcomes
in human well-being and environmental
sustainability and space especially many
spatial data science methods such as GPS
GPS tracking JS remote sensing and sound
spatial cloud computing methods and I
also do qualitative work I I go to the
communities and do participatory mapping
interviews and focus group discussions
with smallholder farmers and herders to
triangulate like the knowledge or we we
extract or we we get from this
quantitative methods
so
um first topic
um dry land system sustainability okay
so my interest in this topic started
from my learning of the tragedy of the
commons all right when I was starting
here
um so according to Jeff Hardin so ruined
this destination towards Oman Rush it's
pursuing his um at time only his
um so this is a direct quote his own
best interest in society that believed
in the freedom of the commons so use the
likely the Pastoral system is a very
classic example of a tragedy of the
commons right because every herder using
that same patch of like um posture
anyone will have an interest to add more
cows to the to the to the system because
the benefit is always greater than the
cost right benefit is one causes one
over n right shared by everyone so like
why don't I keep doing that right so
that's like a like uh that's Harden's
argument
and um looking at a photo like this so
people are more likely to like um to be
convinced by Harden's argument right
because partialists they are irrational
and then that will eventually lead to
our unsustainable pastoral system so
this is a picture I took uh in my field
work in southern Ethiopia and um I would
say this is a little bias to capture
what's going on in the system because as
Scholars we always go in the dry season
because if you go in the west season
your vehicle will get stuck in the mud
and you you don't want to call another
vehicle to save you and then you go back
in the months and and and say that's a
stock vehicle right so so it's a it's
it's very biased so I only return in the
ring season Once and the landscape looks
totally different okay I just want to
highlight that ends up the solution to
um to the tragedy of the commons is the
large-scale migration so this is the
Empire Northern Western far north
western China the Qatar pastoralists
migrate between the Gobi deserts and
outside mountains that cover distance
Over Us in some cases over 300
kilometers one way from the other to the
mountains ends up so this is a place
like throughout my talk I will talk I
will mention like um how like my
interaction with sips or at that time we
call it CSS right I took many CSS
courses especially with Professor uh de
Gloria he he helped me a lot um in those
those kind of work and I still remember
in my first semester here I took his uh
GIS class and then the following
semester took again to this class facial
modeling and Analysis I probably this is
a map like I created like in his JIS
life sometimes I sneak in to the
Bradfield lab because
natural resources graduate students at
least me some of them like including me
were assigned to the chicken chicken the
chicken house F house we call it it's
very hot you know in a humid when the
temperature is up is around 30 oh my God
Centigrade so that's why like I like to
use the facilities there and you see
like this is like a steady Edits edits
right he put the like or give me some
like feedback back in like 2011. so this
morning as I Was preparing for this like
oh Steve helped me like uh when I was up
preparing the field where coming up with
my ideas right those are the two courses
I took with uh Steve and uh another one
is a CSS um six uh
69000 the scientific methods in practice
and which is a co-taught by Gary is
already emirators now but he said in my
class I'm basically a ta people or the
author of this book which is hugao he
wrote this book and throughout the
semester it was him was teaching this
class so
it's a it's really a like a
philosophical reflection of scientific
methods which inspired me a lot back
then
so just a little story there and then
okay back to the topic so large skill
migration as a solution right right but
personalism actually as um is the is the
is the chief at least in the context of
foreign
is a preferred livelihood strategy
because if you just we look at the
annual household income right it um just
dominates all other it is just preferred
um it's higher compared to our other
five
um livelihood like uh strategies such as
Agri pass Solace drop bombers
smallholder which labor and the hired
herder but even even if so like the
governments like their solution right
um in the Chinese context is to
sedentarize them they construct this uh
centralization villages and subsidized
them like sell them to the herders at a
lower cost as a incentive
to convince them to move into those
villages
and uh one in our inner like a survey
with those herders we do see that
actually almost you see yes on unsettled
houses like are you will for the
unsettled households the majority of
them they do want to settle they want to
move into the villages because they know
doing this kind of a large-scale
migration is not easy especially in the
context of our climate change
environmental degradation but their
experience after they moved into the
houses you see this appealing paint from
the wall for quality of those houses of
a critical concern and this is just one
example and finding Bible livelihoods
are like in those sedentarized Villages
it's also very hard for them because um
many of them they didn't do not have the
skills to transition into non-pastor
livelihood strategies
so therefore the gap between the Synergy
State like food security and the
environmental sustainability right with
the real with the reality which is a
trade-off right either compromised
environment for food or compromised food
for environment right motivates me to
like uh like uh I think it's important
to address this yeah but
um what's more like uh we what's worse
down the ground is uh as a as a loose
loser scenario where we see like for
example using Jam people the herders
they struggle with their livelihoods
integrating environments right so
closing desk apps become the fundamental
goal in my research
so then
after like I did my Masterwork in in
xinjiang then I went to Southern
Ethiopia to do to do more work
um so these are the five uh five of our
study sites um in the borana zone of
Ethiopia which is uh just uh north of
north of Kenya
so again for my PhD project I received
even more um support from sips faculty
especially from Steve like the first I
remember I when I started my PhD I asked
me ah Steve can you serve on my
um graduate Community PhD comedian it
was like I'm going to retire so but now
when I finished it still hasn't reported
you're retired he said it was in office
retirement but um
I don't remember exactly when he retired
but he was still here but anyway so you
see some of his large a lot almost like
recent Publications like before he
retired was that with me so I'm happy to
see that and um and he
um later he he actually
um like applied for funding to support
the GPS tracking of the cows uh in
southern Ethiopia so that's that's
support by Steve and also I took two um
classes on in sips one by uh Tom Sylvia
and uh Carl Nicholas and that class was
in this classroom I still remember
Professor Nicholas he was doing this
so he drove like a flower structure like
with two hands something like that
making it very hard for me to like to
keep up with his Pace because he used
two hands to draw like a Sim like those
those structures right but it's it's
really amazing to see how he he like her
do this kind of things and another class
I took was um with Melissa Luca on the
taxonomy I took those class because
um because I I wanted to
um identify the scientific name of um
plants in Ethiopia in my study area so
quite it's it's quite like a challenge
for me to to take those and then do the
field field work and bring the the plant
specimens to the National bearment of
UCO and Judah and identify the
scientific name that took quite a long
time especially for someone like who had
didn't have much training before then on
this topic
so the research question about
achievement synergies which is up right
in that context Synergy means lifestyle
production and the ritual and
sustainability we need to have both
methods this is up well I would say this
is one of the novel
um approach we we've ever we we we did
in that in that project is the GPS
tracking right so Steve was a major GI
in this effort so we
um this is our collaborator based in
Boise Idaho is a ranged scientist he
designed those GPS Scholars and shipped
them to Ethiopia and we also put them
together and um and deploy them on the
accounts in total we did a uh we put our
GPS callers down 60 cows
um
um in five study sites for four years
every five minutes we got a like a
coordinate like update so that means
over millions of points right that is
spatial and temporal information
and in addition to that we did a mind
mapping with herders and Magdalene um
she helped me with um with preparing
those Maps so lots of support from from
CSS um faculty back then and uh and then
we also did a plan survey to to to study
the rangeland vegetation so now some
results
so um for this one so we see on the
Range one side so I'm just using one
slide to summarize what we see is like
moderate grazing pressure contributes to
uh range and sustainability in the sense
that is the dense ambitious cover or the
sparse Woody plant cover but when the
gradient pressure is too low the system
tends to shift into this kind of dense
tickets right and the cattle will have a
hard time to access the audacious
resources in the understory but when the
pressure is too high right the system
tends to shift into this uh Bushland
right very little ambitious stuff for
cattle grazing only those kind of Acacia
shrubs
and the on the other hand the other um
synergists that go is livestock
production so right we think of a
lifestyle production outcomes you think
about the body conditions of those cows
right
not good good like a thing ones and bad
ones those are some from the herders
perspective they will think like that
but of course we didn't measure their
body weight change over time right but
with GPS tracking that can shed light
um on this livestock production outcomes
right so I'm just here putting two cows
uh temporal dynamics of their behavior
so the top one you see spend a lot of
time effort on traveling that means fast
moving from
um in the in the morning and afternoon
late afternoon to rush between the camp
location their their base camp to this
major green sites go there fast and then
come back right but during the day they
have they will have opportunities to to
Grace but this one below is a belongs to
the the owner is a
mobile herder right that means he
relocates his cow to different locations
in the dry season so so yeah during the
time of Camp during the day of our camp
relocation you do work a long distance
but once you relocate to a seasonal
breathing resource then you basically
the car wake up and the start to pray so
they minimize they can minimize the
traveling behavior
um like uh throughout the season
and if we link those temporal dynamics
of cattle behavior to their spatial
utilization pattern we'll see that right
the one owned by a sedent rice herder
right this is a base camp location and
as it gets drier the cow needs to walk
longer distance or towards the other
side this is the in the mountains right
that means the cattle need to even climb
up the hill to access the resources but
on the right side temperature rotation
right really help with minimizing
traveling Behavior this is the base camp
location the web season the cow is based
somewhere here right and then the dry
season comes the cow is relocated to
different patches for arrangement
resources so that's why we see this so
the the the take-home message here is a
spatial resource access is key is
crucial to achieve student registered
outcomes in that at least in that
context
so the next question is um what are the
determinants of our spatial resource
access so here I'm going back to austrum
Theory
um like second tier variables in the
framework for analyzing a social
ecological system so of course obviously
I didn't have um like data for all the
variables that she identified but um but
as she said in the paper it's okay
especially um um so you you just get um
like as many variables as possible right
so for me I got like in the subhaster
system and the size of a resource
resource system I use the herding extent
as a to measure this and the
productivity
um using and using vegetation index and
for users we have a community number of
households in the community and location
we use distance uh to roads as the
measurements and the outcome here is the
synergistic alcohol achieved about
camera location right so here I'm
skipping like the big regression tables
and just to show you the significant
results right all those um predictors
have a significant jobs effect on this
outcome
right including her so so but I would
just explain more in in here so the
implications so first what we find is
the extensive movement is that is a is a
key adaptation to environmental stress
that means uh
um
right that means not this this is the
one because
um from this vegetation index the that's
the vegetation index goes lower
partially it's more likely to do Camp
relocation right this means it's a clear
adaptation to environmental stress and
policy implementation is that camera
allocation should should be recognized
as a as a key strategy to ensure
seasonal access to forage resources in
future pastoral system policy making
instead of encouraging this kind of
sedentralization policy so here I didn't
mention this like same in as in China
the Ethiopian government is also
um encouraging sedenturization
um they they do not have the like the
resources of the Chinese government to
subsidize the construction of
sedentralization villages but they give
up land to people as an incentive say
hey if you're centralized in this
Village you can enclose this much of
land and that's your private land for
crop cultivation right they are trying
to give incentives to to encourage
certain behaviors and second is um
related to the resource herding extent
here so of course right a larger herding
extent can facilitates uh extensive
movement but in this part of the world
the pastoralists um given the increasing
population livestock and human
population
um it's the hurtingness extent is
shrinking so one potential solution to
this is um to facilitate Inter-Community
land sharing to facilitate large-scale
movements and the spatial temporal
redistribution of resources right on a
reciprocal basis
and the third is that it's about a group
size effect a smaller group size in the
community facilitates extensive movement
so this means that the trend um the
effect of group size on the transaction
cost of um of um extensive movement that
is negative and this means that in the
future policy making we need to
facilitate a fear procedure and
participation in reducing the high cost
of agreeing on rules
to coordinate this resource sharing can
provocation and this is you can see this
there is a conjunction in their access
to water this is the boho like pumped
water from
um to to water the cow especially in the
dry season it's necessary to water the
towel at least every three days
otherwise they will be in trouble
so in addition to this kind of GPS
tracking a related uh research right we
also studied that I also studied a
traditional ecological knowledge like um
basically to study the uh the
palatability of different forage species
to four major livestock species in that
part of the world goat camo sheep and
cattle right so is there a beaches or
Woody or the palatability level so this
is the hard part right why I'm preparing
I did took those plant science class
because I wanna I wanna do this so
collect like the plants like specimens
right and bring them to the National
barium of Ethiopia I mean well when we
collect each specimen we ask the herders
their palatability level to the
livestocks issues and based on their um
based on their like um description and
also their perception of their either
increasing or decreasing in their
availability right we simulated um the
the the plant palatability change or
over time as more ambitious plans are
being replaced by Woody plants and we do
see that the rifle
cattle is black cattle and sheep they
will suffer a declining average
probability goats with a more or less
the same than the camels will will will
will have a we have a positive change in
probability over time so actually those
as we can see here the herders are
already adapting their lifestyle
portfolio according to their
understanding of um of their the plant
Dynamics change in in on the rangelands
and actually I would say this is a this
is a not a small deal because um cattle
has very important cultural like
significance in that part of the world
the entire like the the hurting like the
community the boring culture is built on
cattle now you if you're asking them to
change in in their lifestyle species
it's um it's a it's a it's a big change
in there in not just in their choice of
livelihoods and US hurting strategy but
also
cultural change but encouragingly right
we do see that um there is a changing
lifestyle portfolio like especially
um for both rich and poor households
there's a reduction in cattle with
Holdings and also for particle for goats
we see that both groups there's an
increase in the holding of gold and for
we all serious households they're they
are able to increase their camel
Holdings
and also Community engagement right this
is also very important so I created
those um you is this GPS tracking data I
created those maps and uh translated
them into the local language with my the
help of my local collaborators and print
and given those uh give gave this Maps
back to the community so hopefully those
Maps will serve as the tools to help
them
um
um help them
reflect their resource use patterns and
and defend their land tenure from
potential land grabbing rights because
they're encroaching interest from our
business on those lands
So speaking of land grabbing leads to
the second topic I'm not sure like we
have time until
115 okay I'll go a little faster now
okay 115 is four questions or just me
okay
okay Global unrush the second empirical
component and
so what I mean by growth so here when we
Global land rush is a term that's used
by like um like Media or like some
Scholars but here we are using the term
um large-scale land transactions to
refer to the topic it's like land rush
means that it has some negative
connotations and um even like even worse
terms could be like land grabs right
that that is like focusing on the role
of investors like going to the
communities and get land
um so here we use the term transactions
because we believe it's more neutral so
this means land deals made between
investors and host country governments
in the form of um concessions long-term
leases and ownership transfers for
agriculture production this is what we
are we focus on here so this is on the
left is the photo that I took on the
ground in uh so what this crop can can
anyone is it
sugarcane right it's a large sugar cane
plantation so I was probably somewhere
here taking the photo
so you see this large sugar cane
plantation starting like
contrast with the neighboring small
Parcels of a small small holder Taff or
maze patches of smallholder farms so
this is a farm that's built like by
aggregating a smaller farm lands
together and do irrigation and bring
water into this area and then and then
start the sugarcane foundation so that's
just one form of our land trainer change
right there are different forms like
changing from like forests like or
Community forests or like rangelands
into this kind of large-scale
agriculture
so if we look at this phenomenon
globally right the global full regime
means you're actually in transition we
see like um major investor countries go
into
um to the global South right to to look
for land for agriculture development and
if we just um use a network approach to
understand what's going on we do see
that uh those U.S and China
they are the two most important land
investors in the global land transaction
market right indicated by the size
bigger size the more important that
means the higher like the more the
greater amount of land transactions and
the the location right in this network
means that centrality right they play
Central roles in This Global Land Rush
so sometimes like I see story
um like in they blame China for this but
U.S is doing the same right so in yeah
at least this is what um the data
reveals are from this uh blend Matrix
data set that's open access
so motivation why do people want to do
that right towards plantational things
so this is a paper by my colleague in
global development
um so Wendy she argue around Plantation
has been promoted globally as a social
system and imperative and a mentality
right so in plain words right investors
want to convert this kind of a they call
underutilized Forest or rangelands into
all the smallholder farm plots into
these plantations in the large-scale
Farms right too and also the local
government also have it has an incentive
to facilitate this because this will
generate less this is the mango
Plantation right intended for for export
so that will generate like um foreign
currency for their for their for their
government that's very important for
them and why this is a global concern I
would say three major reasons one is a
large extent areas or somewhere between
40 to 120 million hectares of land even
the lower end is greater than the size
of Germany and the social economic
inequality as um as indicated here right
um agribusiness investors competing with
local people for land use and the
environmental Injustice like
deforestation
um and uh and the covering Mission
associated with this land cover change
process
so in sufficient why they're so wound
with our team started to study this
issue right we did a system uh
comprehensive literature review and we
find the three major knowledge gaps in
this topic one is lack of data because
the land language land transactions
um is very secretive right it's a
government and local investor and the
investors Make a Deal
usually they don't publicize so for
Scholars it's very hard to access like
those data in a systematic way and site
selection bias those who
I like called media headlines they are
more likely
like to receive scholarly attention
right and also pre-integration of
outcomes so here's what I mean like most
most
academic research on this topic focus on
the social aspects and some among the
ecological environments about um there
is a lack of integration of social
economic and environmental outcomes so
that's why like when we started to study
this topic right we need to we we we we
decide to focus on the joint outcomes
when we analyze this and uh with
attention to the social inequality and
environmental Injustice issue associated
with the land land tenure change
so I studied this at different uh scales
right at the local level so we we
answered the question of um how changes
in control over land and resources
affect the men and women's labor
allocation livelihoods and well-being so
when we were in the communities we do
see like um men and women we were
treated differently right both of them
work on the farms but women have to take
the plow carry it plow by themselves and
walk choose their assign the pump plots
to work but man at least they will have
a tractor to transport them from the
village to the farm plots
that's what we observe and at first and
then we have the different uh uh like uh
our focus group discussions with with
male and female groups to understand
this so here I'm not going to talk about
the details but just to give a sense of
like a different skills we answer
different questions and the national
level so we'll answer the question of
how does Lambda transaction accelerate
deforestation right the important thing
is um accelerate because um even if like
online transactions doesn't happen in
those areas the growing rural population
in the developing world is also may also
um cut down forests to to grow more food
right so the point is like
um you using an econometric approach
like to to come to to to to do call the
inference on whether land transactions
accelerate deforestation so here we
focus on four countries Ethiopia
Liberia Peru and Cambodia where we can
get a land transaction boundary related
on the polygons right so as I said this
is a very hard to get this kind of data
because of secrecy of those deals
and the global level we study the
drivers and impacts of our land
transactions
so for this one I'm going to into a
little bit more details so first Global
did um so this is the data source that I
mentioned to generate the
um the the network right that I
mentioned earlier it's from this it's an
open source data set called the land
Matrix at that time when I did the
research let's about
2016-17 right there are about 15 000
1500 land transactions globally like as
you can see the distribution here so
with this data set we wanna we what we
first analyze the drivers of This Global
Land Rush by looking by comparing
um the characteristics of a investor and
host countries of land transactions
right according to like our per capita
income agriculture productivity arable
and availability and the water scarcity
right across those four dimensions we do
see there is a flow of like a virtual
flow of land right from Wales here from
yes we also wealthy countries to to more
developed countries right as you see
low-income countries they indeed
predominantly serve as a as a supplier
of land in the global land rush so
because of time not going to other
details in the other three
but what is the more important question
is right the consequence of this like
there are many studies on deforestation
but so that's why I'm I think um but
covering emissions from this process
hadn't been started that much so um so
that's um we see I don't know our our
potential contribution so and we only
studied the issue at emissions
um at the land conversion stage right so
it's a long supply chain and it can uh
have um have um have um
like a more common generated from this
process but here this is just a
represent starting point which is like
from land use conversion this is what I
took in Western Ethiopia the photo so it
shows like this newly crew cleared Force
to grow soybeans in Ethiopia you see the
cleared like Woodlands it should be like
a burn
and then you see those soybean ceilings
in the on those lands and there are two
major sources of emissions right at this
stage biomass and the soil organic
carbon so those are there are some
um globally available data sets that we
use to for this estimation
although biomass carbon right once you
clear they're all lost by soil organic
carbon losses a different story so we
refer to the literature I mean this is
just of the average number right because
at different locations that's um the the
percentage of loss is different so right
from forest to problem 42 loss posture
to crop 40 95 and crop to crop like
small holder crop to large scale crop
right um zero percent loss so with that
kind of variation taking into
consideration then we need to think
about right one-way chain what's the
starting point land cover and what's the
ending point at any point it's clear
it's it's cropland right by starting
point we need to so here we use um the
2001 modus land cover
um global data set um to to do the
salinity's classification using Google
Earth's engine and master water
permanent Wetlands Urban and
non-vegetated lands because land
transactions are unlikely to to happen
right in those areas so we need to
explore them probably in our in
retrospect we should we can exclude more
areas like such as by considering the
slope or some some other environmental
covariates but um this is as I said it's
just representing like our first step to
answer this question
so we need to consider about the
implementation strategy right
the first is the business as usual
right as an investor you would clear all
the lens to maximize your economic
return right convert this this is in
central Ethiopia this is a sort of a
typical Savanna landscape you see
there's a tiny like three canopies
sports tree canopies of income but then
after implementation they are all
cleared to establish these large-scale
Farms right right as an investor you
would um you would do this
and then this means um for first posture
and whatever landscape the prior
landscape is you convert all of them
into cropland and then based on this um
some scenario we calculated the total
transaction area biomass carbon loss and
the soil organic soil carbon laws
but what's um the next strategy is what
we propose um as that can be used as a
policy tool to to to how to to reduce
carbon emission from this process
basically to enforce environmental
regulations to protect forests but then
this is a this is like then the question
the challenge here is what kind of
environment um like a regulations and
how such regulations can be enforced
underground throughout the um like the
global topics that's our challenge right
even if in Ethiopia let's say the
central government say you need to
retain at least 20 percent of um natural
vegetation on the landscape but when it
comes to ground implementation that can
be very different across different
regions so that's why what we did is
like to apply the first administrative
unit level deforestation rates in the
past 15 years as the level that can be
enforced Underground
to determine the level of the
enforcement that we can do like globally
right as you can see here on the right
side we do see some natural vegetation
that is being retained retained on this
land transaction site at least this is
better than cutting all the natural
vegetation right
so then this diagram shows
shows the before and after so that means
like we for the forest we retain
whatever level that can be imposed
underground and see how like how much
carbon emission that we can we can
reduce then then again we use a Google
Earth's engine to determine the tree
cover loss percentage and the forest
cover percentage loss of so for the
technical Parts I'm not going to the
details and just a little bit more here
this is uh shows the the main results
right it's about Synergy it's in this
case it's not necessarily about the
Synergy but it's more about managing the
trade-offs between emissions and
agriculture production as we can see
here so if we change from business as
usual to regulate the scenario
um with some
um like meaning uh enforcing environment
Forest protection policies then biomass
emission can be reduced to about 15 of
the BAU scenario and soil organic carbon
loss can be reduced to about 40 percent
but at the same time nearly 60 percent
of transacted land can still be
implemented for agriculture production
right so this is a um this means like um
if um
um we need to recognize um most goals
carbon emission and also food security
especially in Africa with growing
population we do need to produce more
food the question here is weird
do we like decide that we can let this
kind of um Capital driven Agricultural
Development to happen and at the same
time we save those high carbon value
forests right that's um the main message
so I would just spend the last two
minutes to briefly go to talk about the
future directions right one is built on
the my first topic that I talked about
is I just transitioned in the dry lands
right as the system transition from this
into more like um from like um more like
a
cropping system from this uh hurting to
to cropping them how can those um
herders like the local people adapt to
those changes
and the second is about land system
change and Global housing inequality
basically focus on this but to study the
drivers of land system change and two
major mechanisms zoonosis which are
zones spillover and the poor in security
and it's a global Health inequality and
actually I was started to explore a
little bit of those uh to to understand
agricultural development and its
consequence on zoonos and spillover all
right because of existing research has
already shown that uh major zoonotic
disease host species such as passing
Birds bats and rodenza they're more
likely to
us right and this interface between
natural and human dominated systems so
so that's why like land transactions
like as a driver of this well we'll
certainly increase this boundary between
those so as um so at the first step
we're mapping This Global hotspots of
our zoonosis build overs
because of land transactions new topics
that I just started to explore in my
first two months
um back here is like one is a circular
about nutrient economy for aggress for
system transition
um um when we have a proposal right now
reviewed by USDA Neva and another
potential project is rice Farm rice
farming on seasonally flooded lands as
adaptation to climate changing uh New
York state right so as big wheels of
climate change more lands in in here
they have been seasonally flooded if we
can do Rice farming on those
um on those lands right it will come it
will turn those kind of
um how to say those disasters into
product production opportunities right
so yeah again this is an example of
global development right it's not just
about what's going on in Africa but also
here in New York state
so that's it for my talk today thank you
yeah unfortunately no yeah that was my
last trip
to those communities I really hope like
uh we can raise some funds and go back
to the communities and see whether those
information have an impact have any
effect on their resource user and
patterns right that's that that's my
hope that I I really want to see whether
that's that's having any events in those
communities actually they say the the
cost of um of making this map
is more expensive than a goat
they were that my local collaborators
they would say why don't you give them a
go they will be happier than receiving
this kind of um a piece of map I said um
this is what I can do like but but but
you know it's um the mentality is very
different but that's what I hope but uh
when in my like at the when I give this
map back to the communities we discussed
right some of the the younger people
they can they can read those maps and
and say oh this is a whale that I go to
in the dry season that's on our
community school you know they they are
very good at us like a spatial
orientation those are pastoralist
communities so I do hope that this can
have sound effects yeah that's a that's
a good suggestion that maybe we can
there is funds like seed funds from from
somewhere to revisit those communities
I'm not sure like actually you can you
can ask she is working with Chris um
those projects and uh this is um one
actually it's one of our Chris's uh he's
a pi on this I I need to ask him this
question actually if there's any
continuation of um
in this line of thinking yeah thank you
yeah exactly actually I didn't show um
some of the maps that are of a land
sharing it's like Community from like
these are
um at least 50 kilometers away from each
other sometimes they are like we see
evidence of one Community going to the
other to share land with others so they
are already doing this kind of land
sharing on a reciprocal basis yeah it's
the the it's hurting extent is shrinking
for all communities but uh this kind of
Institutions to facilitate
that kind of land sharing yeah it's a
it's a it's very crucial for them to to
to keep like to maintain a relatively
higher level of Mobility I'm not sure if
that's your question or oh
yeah I do think so right because um
actually it's um they can
minimize the working right that reduced
like a stress for the cows right
um you um in in there in their daily
grazing like um activities
right exactly so yeah
so where I owned or you
um
sure yeah there was a big literature
like on on those topics so from the
investors perspective and also from more
from the local people's perspective like
an interaction with the local people
they are more than happy to get more
involved because
um because that means higher return for
them but once you establish these large
scale forms that means less demand for
labor higher mechanization right those
people basically for actually let's let
me just use this example
for this one what they received is a
share according to share of Revenue
according to their land contribution
to this sugarcane Foundation then then
that basically freed up the labor in the
within the household that they can go to
the nearby towns and the cities to serve
as wage laborers
and also all work in the Chinese Factory
like there is a Chinese economics um
just nearby they just go to make shoes
in the company and earn a wage so
actually local people are more than
happy to do that I I I wouldn't say all
of them but some of them they are happy
to do that but the thing is a lack of
opportunities like um
um like um like um Chinese economic zone
if there are more of those like um that
can provide or employment opportunity
especially for the young people in
Africa I think there's some actually
um this will work out even better but
then but actually one of the major
concerns is like once you do this what
happens to the local people they lose
land they lose means of livelihoods they
at best get a share of the revenue from
the sugarcane Foundation that's the best
they can expect because those they they
don't want to hire local people and this
is in Central in the agriculture our
body if you go to the Pastoral regions
or in in the sort of the periphery of
Ethiopia then those local people have
very little skills of farming and the
investors are very unwilling to train
those people and then have them
Farm like work to a farming work on
there on their on their farm so so we do
see those current it depends really
depends on where in this part of
Ethiopia I think
it may work it may lead to better
outcomes compared to others that's why
it leads to a lot of in confrontation
between the investors and local people
even the people can burn their sugar
cane plantation or sabotage their their
tractors or that something like that
that happened
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu